just saw some paperwork there with
Daniel talking about Baker Mayfield
thinks he'll be a top 15 pick so Daniel
thanks for joining us good morning
let me start with the news you got Rosen
and Arnold who declared if you were
gonna rank the quarterbacks who will be
available in the draft who's one and two
three and four your list yeah my list
right now dan I just over the last day I
just went back and looked at all the
third and 6-plus throws for all these
guys which is a good way to kind of sort
through it and get rid of all the bubble
screens and all that nonsense and the
way I would stack it right now I still
I'm kind of rolling on Sam darn 'old I'd
have Darnell I would go Donald Rosen
then it would be Alan for me basically
on the upside then I'd have Mayfield for
I think those four guys are kind of cut
above everybody else right now are they
that close because I think you had
Mayfield as a top 15 pick so four in the
first 15 do you see yeah I mean there's
will be in my top 15 players but I
expect him to go in the top 15 picks is
just a supply and demand thing there
around the league so my teams needing
quarterbacks i I do think he would have
going in the top 15 if he was six four
where would Baker Mayfield go I think
you would yeah I think you'd go a few
spots higher I mean it's balanced to him
it's not just the size thing when you
watch these guys all back-to-back Dan I
mean he is kept so clean in that offense
they spread you from sideline to
sideline and he barely gets any pressure
that you know is at the Rose Bowl you
saw in the second half where Georgia was
able to get to him a little bit he
struggled and when you watched Arnold I
think some people have this idea that
Donald's playing with you know NFL
players all over the field their
offensive line is not very good he got
touched up he got these guys I don't I
don't think the average Jill out there
realizes how much pressure he was under
really from Game one all the way through
the whole season what's the one item
that you're looking for with these
quarterbacks as an NFL scout the one
item that they have to have
well I mean you start with you know
accuracy accuracy and decision-making
those are the two most important things
that you that you let you focus on and
that and when you talk about Baker
Mayfield those are two things that he's
been pretty good at but you can't just
look at it in a vacuum you've got to
take it all into account in terms of
what offense they're running who they're
playing and who's playing with them so
that's where you kind of start with it
the the challenging one I think they
even have opinions all over the place on
these guys you have different orders
some guys and I think Josh Allensworth
the first pick some guys are gonna think
Josh Allen shouldn't be a top three
round pick you're gonna have just
opinions all over the place who has the
biggest upside and who could be a bust I
would say Allen has the highest ceiling
and the higher end the lowest floor so
there's the most risk involved with him
hmm but he is the best athlete of all
these guys and he does it in a six foot
five plus two hundred and thirty-five
pound frame so he's got all the all the
tools when I look at teams Dan you start
trying to figure out who fits where you
look at the Giants with Eli for a couple
years and you could kind of salt away a
guy like Josh Allen that might be a nice
a nice set up there yeah but the only
concern I would have is if you're Eli
Manning and you're willing to commit a
couple more years do you want to waste
that for lack of a better description
that number two overall pick when you
could get say Quan Barkley who can help
you right now for a defense that you
spend all that money on that we thought
was super bowl caliber right yeah I mean
that would be my concern of taking Josh
Rosen that high if you're the Giants
yeah the challenge just is just it's all
comes down to philosophy do you think
this team is good enough to win a
championship in the next two years with
with you I mean if that's the decision
you come to and and you can flush from
your memory what we saw this year from
the rest of the team you think you can
do you can plug in a guy likes a qualm
Barkley who is the best player in the
draft I don't think it's close I think
he's clearly the most talented guy in
the draft if you think you can win a
championship in the next couple years
then you do it you would take say Kwan
Berkeley but if you think you're far
away you think
not on the opportunity to get what could
be a you know quarterback for your team
for a decade plus why is it the best
player in the draft the most talented
player doesn't always go number one
because it's always gonna be a
quarterback driven league guy that
Sheikh Juan Barkley that you you think
all right
and I get plug and play and I got a guy
who's great when I don't even know about
these quarterbacks I I have no idea but
I know more about say Quan Barkley and
what he's gonna help me from day one I
have no idea of any of these
quarterbacks see the field this year
yeah I think I think look Josh Rosen to
me you can plug and play him he's ready
to go right now I think Donald it needs
to work out some kinks but I think he's
got tremendous upside and value but with
you right now biggest bang for your buck
is probably you know it is going to be
say Kwan Barclay the best player it's
just the quarterback position it's hard
to win it's hard to win consistently if
you're not set at that at that spot and
in some of these teams you look at the
Giants they're sitting here thinking hey
we never pick up here I mean we couple
Super Bowls recently we're never going
to get the opportunity to get a player
of this talent this high in the near
future so you got to take it why it's
there Daniel Jeremiah and if they'll
network analysts but Rosen in the
comments that I don't know if he said
anything publicly but they were
attributed to him that he didn't want to
play for Cleveland what do you make of
that and if you're Cleveland you shy
away well I mean yeah that's gonna be
tricky that's the challenge with Josh is
gonna be that you're dealing with okay
you know personality-wise is you want to
be there that's never a good place to
start guy doesn't want to be there that
positions hard enough as it is and then
to me I think you also factor in the
durability with him and that to me would
scare me off if I was you know had that
first pick and had the choice of all
these guys that's why if I was if I was
Cleveland I'd probably look more toward
Sam Donald if golfin wins were in this
draft
what would the ranking be oh that's a
good one
obviously it's tough to disassociate
what you know now well no tell me what
you thought of golf and wins
yeah and wait yeah you know when they
were being drafted and and if you can
and then you know we can apply to these
guys who are going in now
yeah I would say just based off grade
off of draft grade I would have higher
grades on on on Rosen andand Arnold
Arnold first that rose and I would have
those two guys carried higher grades for
me coming out than golf and Wentz now
obviously they've performed quite well
and it's worked out really well for the
Rams and for the Eagles but just based
off college draft grade I would have
those guys a little bit ahead how many
first-round players will be in the
national title game in your opinion oh
man gosh off the top of my head I think
you're probably safe saying a handful
you know the the challenge with
Georgia's guys as you're looking at
running backs in a year where I think
it's just so loaded
I think Sony Michelle and Chubb and in a
down year at the position our easy
first-round picks but this year there's
so many dudes I could see those guys
slipping into the second round and those
are kind of the marquee players on their
offense you flip over the defense and
row kwan smith we'll see what he decides
to do but he's he's right up there in
terms of the best linebackers in the
country what about Alabama's defense
Alabama's defense Minka Fitzpatrick is
you know if he decides commas is a slam
dunk and then you've got a bunch of guys
I think they've got a kind of bunch of
guys in that second tier I don't think
this Alabama defense is quite as good as
it's been in the past but I think you'd
have a lot of guys in that you know two
three four round range a bunch of those
type of players you know you're right
and I'm it's weird that you have an
Alabama team where there's nobody that
you really focus on you know then let's
say you remove yourself from the SEC or
an Alabama fan that that hey I got to
watch this guy you know Georgia has the
two running backs but I want to see what
you know the the freshman quarterback
does against Nick Saban but that TuneIn
factor of you got to see this guy play
not necessarily there it would have been
there with Oklahoma far more I think
than Georgia
yeah the challenging thing with Alabama
is if you look at it from an NFL
standpoint the best player on their
offense is Calvin Ridley but they're
just not very good throwing the football
you don't you
to really see him featured like the way
we saw Mary Cooper get featured back in
the day why don't we have great
quarterbacks in the SEC I don't know I
that's a good that's a good question I
mean I think that they are so committed
to winning at the line of scrimmage in
that league and they're so run oriented
maybe that's that's part of it you don't
spend it when you're on heavy offense
then you think about the reps in
practice and how many reps you spends
throwing the ball versus running the
ball that adds up over three and four
years it's kind of what they major in so
I think that's somewhat that's part of
it and the other thing is if you're if
you're a top rated quarterback in the
country you want to go to Oklahoma
speaking of quarterbacks Lamar Jackson
if he comes out or he goes back and his
NFL future is what he is I think you
know some people have debated is he a
quarterback is your receiver I think
he'd definitely be given a chance at the
position at the quarterback position
accuracy to me he'd be the one that is a
major concern there but man he's a you I
think if you if you went and got Lamar
Jackson you kind of give yourself over
to hey we're going to be as don't read
heavy team we've seen the Chiefs dabble
in it we've seen the the Eagles dabble
in it I think our I think just fallen
commit to it and he could hold up
because man he's he's the most dynamic
runner at that position that we've seen
since dick always good to check in with
you Daniel we'll do it as we get closer
to the draft thanks for joining us thank
them that's our Daniel Jeremiah NFL
Network analyst former NFL scout for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]